[Music]
hello I'm Dr Marsha Pierce and I'm an
assistant professor in the department of
pharmacology at Midwestern University in
Downers Grove Illinois and I'd like to
thank you for joining my talk
preclinical evaluation of marine natural
products for Neuroscience drug
Discovery by the end of this talk um
participants will a be able to describe
the drug development process and
timeline identify challenges associated
with neuropharmacological drug
development learn about how the marine
environment contributes to Unique
metabolite structure and learn about
upcoming Marine natural products in
preclinical and clinical
use so how does a drug get to Market
initial hits through uh screen
screenings and synthesis um identify a
compound that binds to a target of
interest and when those compounds are
identified they generally don't have the
appropriate properties that will get
them to Market initially they're going
to have issues with solubility they're
going to bind to things that you don't
want to you can have side effects so
that initial synthesis examination and
screening occurs in various cellular
cultures and when we have identified
a compound of Interest as you can see in
the bottom of this that could be
anywhere between 10,000 and 25,000
compounds through this basic research
screening we then move approximately 10
to 20 of them to the preclinical testing
in animals this preclinical testing
generally takes place in two different
animal models one rodent generally Mouse
and one non-rodent generally rabbit now
in these models it looks for ability to
cross the blood brain barrier it looks
for dosing safety side effects Target
effects what it could potentially treat
they also do longer term studies looking
for
carcinogenicity uh for genotoxicity or
mutagens and especially for Reproductive
toxicity looking to see if the male
Mouse is then able to go on and
reproduce or the female Mouse and so
forth if the compound passes all of
these initial tests an investigational
new drug application or indd application
is shown at where the red arrow is
located and if that investigational new
drug application is approved by the US
Food and Drug Administration the FDA it
goes into your initial phase one
clinical trials about half of the
compounds can make it into this phase
one clinical trials looking for safety
first we're looking for the appropriate
dosing we want to make sure that there's
no major side effects and we want to
make sure that the compound is safe in
humans next if it man manages to achieve
all of these then it moves forward into
your phase two clinical trials at which
times we're looking for efficaciousness
does the drug treat what we expect it to
and is it efficacious or more
efficacious than current options already
on the
market if it Mak this goal then we next
look in the human clinical trials at the
phase three is it worth the risk there
are a lot of drugs that have very
terrible side effects including a number
of your
chemotherapeutics but sometimes they're
used and chosen because their effects on
cancer are better than living with or
dying with said illness if it passes the
phase three and is determined to be
worth the risk then a new drug
application is f filed with the FDA if
there's potential for abuse that drug
will also be reviewed by the drug
enforcement agency the
DEA once a drug is approved it goes into
the phase four or the post marketing
surveillance at this time they continue
followup clinical trials and also watch
for potential side effects that may have
not been caught in the early phase one
two and three trials after 20 years the
patent expires and generics become
available notice the attrition of these
compounds over time from your initial
basic research to get one drug to Market
in general it takes about 10 to 12 years
and about a billion dollars to get a
drug to
Market so Neuroscience drug development
is particularly fraught with a lot of
complications that other drugs don't
don't
have for example when you want to test a
drug for say blood pressure you've got a
very concrete measurement of what the
initial blood pressure was what the
effects are that are seen with the drug
is the blood pressure lowered yes or no
and then any side effects unfortunately
with Neuroscience drug development we're
we're working with very complicated
diseases um including Parkinson's
Alzheimer's and stroke with the nine
leading causes of uh neuro disability
accounting for about1 trillion dollars a
year in total economic burden moreover
there's a lot of factors that complicate
uh this low success rate for example
nearly all CNS Therapeutics treat
symptoms rather than modifying the
disease when we're treating chronic pain
we're treating the symptom of it we're
not modifying the overall um um effects
that are causing the pain in the first
place next diagnosis are often based on
clusters of clinical symptoms rather
than objective laboratory measures for
example a recent drug that did make it
to Market
ainab uh is used for Alzheimer's disease
and it was found that this monoclonal
antibody can reduce the amalo beta
plaques unfortunately those plaques
aren't always corresponding or
correlating well with overall cognitive
decline and even though this drug has
been approved it doesn't appear to have
any major benefits for cognitive effects
at this time that have been identified
it also has some pretty serious side
effects including brain swelling and uh
brain bleeds it costs about
$56,000 a year for this drug therapy to
be used and a lot of insurance companies
don't pay for for it all of these
combined make it a very expensive and
costly process even if it actually gets
approved clinical trials often assess
subjective measures that are fraught
with both Placebo and nobo effects some
of your drugs for your various
depression or anxiety it's looking at
how the patient feels some of your other
drugs are looking at cognitive deine and
they try to assess that in as subjective
of a or in a objective a manner as they
can but generally subjective measures
are and so you're going to have the
placebo effects where people think
they're getting the therapy when they're
actually not or you can have nobo
effects where people are getting the
placebo but believe that they are
actually being treated uh with said drug
and therefore have complicating factors
all of these combined result in larger
longer and and more expensive clinical
trials than for a variety of other
medical
indications so why are we interested in
Marine natural products about 70% of the
world's biodiversity is found in our
oceans it can be found in fish in
crustaceans in microbes and fungi even
in the biowaste from the various
organisms but one of the interesting
things there are some structural and
functional things that these um animals
and microbes use to uh fortify
themselves but their primary way that
they communicate with one another is
through chemical warfare which
interestingly has provided some very
unique primary and secondary metabolites
that we can't find anywhere else and
that are not found in our uh synthetic
chemical libraries we they have very
unique structures and backbones and a
lot of that has to do with the fact that
they can have high saline the high
pressure pressure hydrothermal pressure
um you can have ones near the uh
hydrothermal vents in the ocean all of
these these microbes and other organisms
have really adapted and primarily again
through chemical warfare so you can have
enzymes that come from that there are
fungicides different microbes will make
um that can be used for treatment I'll
talk a little bit about um ones that are
potentially uh anti uh
parasitic coming up some of the MC
toxins I'll talk about uh prialt which
is a potent cona toxin that's used for
therapeutic pain as well as one in
clinical trials
Huron um which is tetrodotoxin from the
puffer fish and in a way it stops that
the area from signaling to the brain
that you're feeling that pain there's
also a number of immune modulators
there's a number of biochemicals and
neutrals that have been identified that
are used in com cosmetics and food and
other options as well so the Marine
biodiversity really helps with the
building of these unique chemical
libraries so now we're going to just
look at some of the approved Marine
natural products their derivatives are
inspired drugs and as you'll note from
this slide there's a lot of them that
are um used particularly for cancer if
you look at the first four in the top
left corner you'll see that those are
all similar or nucleotide mimics cabine
which I'll talk about in the use of some
of my studies um is one that's used for
cancer because it uh acts as a c
nucleotide a cyto nucleoside and blocks
then the um transcription and
translation of these and then stops the
ability to reproduce those
cells um there are a number of other new
and upcoming ones that are your an body
drug conjugates that you'll notice in
the lower left corner your Bram ab votan
pitam ab votan a lot of these have a
marine natural product that is connected
by a Linker and then they'll have an
ADC uh the conjugate it's going to have
a monomethyl orost Statin e mmae or an
mmaf what that does is it finds the
target cell that might Express highly
something that's not expressed in your
normal cells it gets taken into the cell
and then that Linker Cleaves and it puts
that mmae toxin in there to specifically
Target cancer cells so that's been a
really interesting new way that these
drugs um have been developed we also
have ones like I mentioned before in
pink in the top uh second from the right
preal is a potent Kono toxin from the
cone snail that has been very effective
in treating severe pain from cancer and
other other things also the tetrodotoxin
from a puffer fish Huron is currently in
phase three clinical trials so there are
a lot of options even for Neuroscience
drug design um that occur in some of
these Marine natural
products so the class of marine natural
products that I'm interested in right
now or the family is called the
manzamine compounds now there are more
than a 100 manzamine compounds that have
been identified from over 16 different
species of sponge and there are a number
of different important factors that may
contribute to these being potent
Neuroscience drugs first uh Pang at all
looked at some structure activity
relationship and cell cultures and they
found that um it had neuro in uh
anti-inflammatory it had
anti-infective um and it was uh very
important for um antibiotic properties
and some of them some antifungal
properties but one of the most important
things that was really interesting that
is it had some antimalarial or
anti-parasitic effects which suggests
that a single drug could both treat the
infection and the neuroinflammation
associated with
that additionally uh Zang at all did a
study using neuro2a cells now neuro2a
cells are from mus musculus uh or Mouse
brain that had neuroblastoma so they're
a neuroblastoma cell line and they're a
unique cell line for initial screens
because they have some neuritogenic or
neuron stem cell- like properties that
make them useful for doing some initial
screening phases in this exam in this um
uh set of experiments they tested
manzamine compounds in these neuro2a
cells and they saw that after 48 Hours
about half of them were neurogenic
and by 72 hours virtually all of them
show neuritogenesis um in these neuro2a
cells now it's really important to note
that these neuroblastoma cell lines have
been known to not be as sensitive as
primary neurons to various toxins so
what we're seeing in NE neurogenesis for
these neuroblastoma cells um may not
translate well to primary neurons so
that's where we then take this research
by stepping into Marine primary cortical
cultures so the goal of This research is
to identify novel neuroactive compounds
for marine natural products we want to
assess the effects on neurite outgrowth
neurotoxicity um to help identify
compounds for the Marine natural
products pre-clinical
pipeline now all of this is done in
compliance with the Midwestern
University in institutional care and use
committee iut protocol approval where we
take pregnant gravid dams at embryonic
day 16 to 18 uh we collect the pups we
dissect out the cortices and remove them
they are then uh the cells are digested
using tripon first and then they're
trated for mechanical separation they
are plated at 1 million cells per Mill
and incubated in 37 degrees Celsius at
5% CO2
um with 90% humidity for 12 days at
about 48 Hours post plating we do add
the cine arabinoside which I talked
about earlier the arac because that
blocks any of your proliferating cells
and leaves us with a pure nmon
culture then for our initial screen we
use tetrodotoxin from the puffer fish
also known as hel neuron because it's a
voltage gated sodium channel blocker and
that causes these uh rhythmic calcium
oscillations to stop we also use
veratridine as our positive control
because that's a voltage gated sodium
Channel activator from the LLY plant and
that causes an in uh influx of sodium
which then results in an influx of
calcium and so that gives us our
positive control we then screen blinded
compounds using them in quintuplet on a
single plate to look if there is um any
changes in the calcium Dynamics if we
see them we go on to do a logarithmic
dose response curve with those compounds
and then also assess for changes in
membrane potential using the flipper
blue membrane uh potential
assay so the first assay that we do at
days in vro2 or
div2 is we remove the media and we apply
4 Millar Flow 8 acetyl methyl esterase
which is a fluorescent die in the cell
and we incubate it for 1 hour and then
immediately prior to running the assay
we remove the fluorescent die and
replace it with locks buffer we place it
into the flipper to Plate Reader which
has an automatic arm that delivers
precise quantities it also has a la
laser to illuminate the fluorescence and
a CCD camera to capture that in the
bottom right corner you can see that it
records all 96 Wells at one time and you
can see the combined result of multiple
wells in the bottom right
corner so next how do we understand the
data the data is graphed on the Y AIS
with fluorescence units and the x axis
over time so for the first two minutes
we allow the rhythmic calcium
oscillations to occur and then as you
can see with the tetrodotoxin on the
left once that tetoto toxin has been
applied the one M micromolar you see a
stop in those rhythmic calcium
oscillations which occurs because the
sodium channel is blocked and that ends
up Downstream blocking these calcium
oscillations we're also looking for
changes in the number or amplitude of
oscillations as you can see in the
veratridine or our positive control now
note that that the units on the Y AIS
vary based on compound so here you can
see that the veratridine has the
rhythmic oscillations going in the
culture until it's applied and then we
see a very large sustained uh influx of
calcium and so that decreases the number
of
oscillations um and has an increase in
the
amplitude so we then took all of the
blinded compounds as you see we've got
tetrodotoxin in the top left corner and
Radine in the bottom right and then
compounds M1 through M21 as they were
labeled and with those we saw a few that
had slight increases in the amplitude of
oscillations as marked by these green
arrows we also saw some with a slight
decrease in the oscillation number or
amplitude as marked by these yellow
arrows overall though we did not see
anything as dramatic as we see with the
tetrodotoxin or the veratridine
suggesting that there's not major
effects on the calcium Dynamics so in
this instant we chose not to continue
with the dose response
curves next we're looking at neurite
outgrowth assays and we analyze these
using image J package Fiji with neuron J
plug-in and when we're looking for total
neurite outgrowth we take a image that
we have taken using a con confocal
microscope that has been uh had a cell
stained with ramine fiden for the
neurites and dappy for the um nucleus
and what it does is uses the pixel color
to help semi-automatically trace the
overall neite outgrowth and then it
provides a readout of the outgrowth in
micrometers now in addition to the total
neurite outgrowth in the middle here you
see that we can look at the complexity
looking at the number of processes in
this case there are four processes
coming off the cell Soma and then we
also can look at the total number of
branches as shown on the right where you
can see that there are 15 branches total
in this um cartoon of a
neuron so now we're going to look at
what those results look like here are
individual cells for each compound they
were plated similarly to what I talked
about in the initial calcium assays but
these are plated um at 25,000 cells per
well on a uh GL plate glass cover slip
in a 24 well plate and they're allowed
to settle onto the glass cover slip for
about 3 hours at which time we put a
single dose of each of the compounds in
this case we chose 10 Micro
which is a relatively strong dose so
should give us a response if we're going
to see one and from there we looked to
see if there were any increases in what
would be neurite outgrowth compared to
our negative control in the top left
which has just the vehicle uh DMSO or
our positive control in the bottom right
which has the
veratridine and as you can see here
there were a number of them highlighted
in these green boxes that showed what
appeared to be increased neurite
outgrowth compared to the negative
control and then there were a number
that showed some bbing or um other signs
of neurotoxicity that we can see in the
cells as highlighted in these yellow
boxes so that data is exported from
image J into uh graph pad prism for
analysis looking first at the total
neurite outgrowth across the compounds
for 10 cells for each compound and here
the dev standard deviation is shown by
the error bars and we looked at any then
that were above that standard deviation
as potentially neur neurogenic in this
initial screening assay and those are
marked by the green asterisks here we
then wanted to confirm that we also Alo
saw similar changes in the complexity by
looking at the number of processes
coming directly off the Soma and the
total number of branching by these
various compounds and consistent with
what we saw in the last slide we saw
many of those same compounds were again
indicated based on the number of
processes and the number of branching so
from there we unblinded those compounds
and identified uh manzamine a 8 methoxy
manzamine a 12 propoxy manzamine a 12
isob oxy manzamine a ATL 297 irisin one
and Pine and we also have the
veratridine positive control shown here
in the uh bottom right and that was our
positive control voltage gated sodium
Channel activator so from there we are
currently doing dose response curves for
the neurite outgrowth assay for those
compounds that were identified as
potentially
neuritogenic we're also going to use
proprium iodide and fluorine diacetate
to do live dead assays assessing for
neurotoxicity on a dose response curve
for those that we interested in as
potentially neuritogenic because we want
to know at which concentrations they may
also be toxic but we also are interested
in the ones that are potentially
neurotoxic as I mentioned before both
pre and tetrodotoxin are ones that are
neurotoxic but at lower doses have been
shown to potentially be therapeutic in
pain uh these may also have other
potential therapeutic properties as well
and then from there we're going to
further analyze potential Pathways um
that contribute to
neurogenesis and so now I'm going to
talk about a compound that we have
looked a little bit further into um with
some previous work that I've done uh to
show how that pathway analysis go so one
of the compounds that we've been very
interested in is brevetoxin 2 it's a
member of the braev toxin 1 through 10
family that comes from Kina brevis or
the red tide um and it is a voltage
gated sodium Channel activator and so
with that voltage gated sodium Channel
activator on the pre synaptic neuron
that can cause a release of glutamate it
can also on the post synaptic neuron
cause voltage gated sodium channels to
activate um and causing an influx of
calcium but with that glutamate it
canbin to your nmba receptor here uh
marked as glue n2b which causes an
influx of calcium that influx of calcium
then helps activate the light blue
molecule cam K2 which then activates the
small G protein rack and that small G
protein rack becomes activated and
activates Downstream pack one and pack
one then goes on to activate the Killin
cycle which is important for the fa
actin growth that results in that
neurite
outgrowth now from these initial cell
studies we can then go ahead and take it
into a mouse model and so in this study
here we've used the epicortical
brexin and we applied it in a poststroke
model because right now there is no
Therapeutics for uh poststroke recovery
beyond the uh initial TPA and other
things it's all physical therapy now in
that pumber region um about five days
poststroke you're going to have some
cells that are amendable to that Nate
out growth and connectivity but they
have a tonic gabaergic inhibition that's
kind of blocking that activity so what
we did first is we did a slight food
restriction and we tested to see if the
mice were left or right-handed we then
did motor training with whichever hand
they were to have them reach out and
learn how to eat various pieces of pasta
and then as day Zero marked here with
the lightning bolt we did the photo
thrombotic stroke 1.5 millimeters from
bregma to affect wrist rotation and the
strength in their three three midle
digits then we did a motor assessment
the next day at five days poststroke
where we're in that tonic gabaergic
inhibition we drove the voltage gated
sodium Channel activity by brevetoxin
application and then the next day we
assessed their motor activities and at
10 pamle 100 pamle and a thousand pamar
dose uh we did see that they had
increased ability to eat their pasta
they had increased um or decreased foot
faults and their performance on the
catwalk was unchanged suggesting that
improved motorist assessment occurred at
that 1000,000 pamer um doses we also
then looked at the histology and we
found enhanced neurite outgrowth and
connectivity suggesting that this could
potentially be a novel therapeutic uh
option for the treatment of post
stroke and finally um I'm am lucky to
work with a very wonderful group of
national and international advisers
staff and students that help to maintain
the Global Marine Pharmaceuticals
pipeline where we track clinical and
preclinical pipeline applications of
various Marine natural product drugs we
also highlight some important new papers
on Twitter and Facebook so please do
check those out as are load located in
the yellow box at the bottom right
corner and finally I would like to um
acknowledge some members of my
laboratory that are very important
including J to aurus who's my technician
uh Mariam but uh M3 medical student
sujan coio an M2 medical student and J
Jacob Draves a master student here at
Midwestern who have all contributed to
the uh mansam mean Project work that we
have going on I'd like to thank our
entire Marine pharmacology dorg team
it's a wonderful team to learn about
these various drugs I'd like to thank
the Midwestern University Department of
pharmacology for supporting my work uh
my collaborators including ining Dr
Alejandro Mayer here at Midwestern
University bill gerwick at the
University of California San Diego Mark
hayon at the Medical University of South
Carolina and most importantly my
post-doctoral mentor and continued
collaborator Dr Thomas Murray at kraton
University thank you for your
time